[Music]
hello this is dr. Frasier Crane I'm
listening
our favorite radio psychiatrist could be
coming back
where would Frasier be now oh well this
is something we've been discussing well
I admit we have wondered where he might
be but he left for Chicago in the blasts
episode of the show so we have to deal
with that at least he left to go be with
his ladylove probably didn't stay with
him but see it's some some meme
evolution is taking place I don't want
to play Frasier and go back to Seattle I
mean it would be so she hates me frankly
I can't blame her I've been a therapist
now for four months so I want to give
you my professional opinion for free
it's all your fault in Kelsey's new
Netflix movie like father co-starring
Kristen Bell his character is now the
one needing a little professional help I
was left at the altar a few days ago and
my dad who I haven't seen since I was
five showed up to my wedding
unannounced he was with the on-screen
father/daughter duo at the Netflix
summer of love press day to get the
scoop on their latest roles so tell me
what it was like just working together
on such an interesting project I really
liked the role because if she was a
woman who thought she knew who she was
there was a lot of dynamic stuff to her
personality and she has this sort of
heartache about being abandoned by her
father and is faced with the decision of
confronting him and deciding whether or
not she should forgive him and that is
for as a character arc you couldn't
really ask for anything better than that
you're gonna go on pretending you're
still fine with what happened the other
day don't really care
you really dug deep into this one
emotionally and as someone who said a
lot of personal tragedies how has this
role been for you yeah um it's
interesting it they're having a lot of
personal tragedies in my life I think
they just always come along for the ride
with you know if you flip that way and
then that's a life you've had so it's
honestly not so much digging deep it
just kind of is there it just comes out
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]